des centaines de déplacés qui attendent
une place en centre d'hébergement
c'est mozambicain fui les combats pour
se rendre à pemba à quelques centaines
de kilomètres de la ville ciblée par le
groupe al chabaab liées à des shs une
attaque terroriste déclenchée le 24 mars
dernier qui a fait des dizaines de morts
quand j'ai compris que ma vie était en
danger
j'ai fui dans la forêt pour me cacher
pour sauver ma vie je me suis caché à
partir de mercredi le 23
jusqu'à hier c'est à ce moment que nous
sommes arrivés ici dans la ville de ma
femme et mon fils était dans la maison
les bandits sont arrivés chez moi ils
sont entrés et les ont tués ce mercredi
l'armée mozambicaine a lancé une
offensive pour tenter de reprendre le
contrôle de la zone
la situation est encore très précaire
mais les opérations semblent progresser
selon un responsable militaire
les soldats sont sur le point de chasser
les terroristes les forces gagne du
terrain
un signe et que nous occupons déjà
pratiquement la ville depuis le 27
jusqu'à maintenant nous faisons cette
intervention
le résultat est que même aujourd'hui si
vous avez eu l'occasion de nous voir
nous continuons à débarquer des troupes
sur le terrain à pemba ou des gymnases
accueil tant bien que mal les réfugiés
les ong présentes apporte un soutien
logistique pour gérer l'urgence
humanitaire
mais difficile pour le moment de savoir
quand la vie pourra reprendre son cours
normal dans la province du cabo delgado
régulièrement ciblés par les groupes
armés depuis plus de trois ans des
attaques qui aurait déjà fait plus de
2600 morts et près de 680 mille déplacés